today was the annual Christmas brunch at
Buckingham Palace but did Harry and
Megan snub the Queen Prince William
behind the wheel six year old Prince
George riding up front in a booster seat
Kate arrived separately with four year
old Charlotte and 19 month old Louie in
the back separate cars the kids split
think there's trouble with the couple
after this royally awkward shrug off
went viral don't worry
after the Queen's brunch the Cambridge
clan left together
but m.i.a from all the festivities
Harry Megan and Archie it's been nearly
six weeks since we saw the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex out together at a
royal event they're still on their
six-week break from official duties and
are at an undisclosed location with
their son and spending time with Megan's
mom Doria but back to this moment we
can't help but keep playing on repeat
Kate and William's PDA game did Kate
brush off her husband as they filmed a
BBC Christmas special our royal source
tells us the two make a point to keep
the PDA to a minimum at public events
because they are the future king and
queen the most you'll get is William
opening a door or putting his hand on
her back plus a rare moment when Kate
puts her hand on William's knee or a fun
hug after a competition I mean compare
the couple with Harry and Megan those
two can be very touchy-feely but in this
moment Kate was mindful that she was
being recorded by multiple cameras and
just wanted to remain professional she
and William are quote happy in a good
place and devoted to their family I have
a very happy Christmas in fact here's a
look at the Cambridge Christmas card
apparently taken over the summer
Kate William and the kids are perched on
a vintage motorbike only Kate signs the
card with her given name Catherine
[Music]